les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est 32 sports qui se dérouleront dans
des sites d'exception des élèves à
l'écoute et particulièrement
enthousiastes ce lundi 4 septembre jour
de rentrée scolaire marquent également
le début d'une année olympique nous
avons souhaité marquer l'événement dans
les Yvelines en réunissant donc des
élèves d'élementaires et des élèves de
collège sur un site exceptionnel puisque
nous sommes au vélo de Rome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et ce vélo
Drôme c'est un site olympique pour
l'occasion un flambeau olympique a été
dévoilé il fera le tour des écoles
yvelinoises et à chaque arrêt ce sera
l'occasion de faire découvrir de
nouvelles activités autour du sport
en deuxième partie de journée les élèves
de primaires ont visité l'ensemble du
vélo de Rome national et ont reçu les
conseils des collégiens pour conduire un
vélo en toute sécurité un moment de
partage et de transmission là en train
de leur faire des tours de vélo sur une
sorte de circuit pour les apprendre
comment faire du vélo et respecter les
panneaux j'aime plus
ces mecs ici comment dire là comment on
fait du vélo là j'ai bien aimé des
casques ont été remis à tous les élèves
participants de quoi bien démarrer
l'année